this is the Tom and Jerry movie um
paranoia paranoia everybody's coming to
get me uh there is just at that moment I
think you just earned you just said
welcome to the mindfuck and we both
started singing that song no that's a
little um that song I remember watching
it and like sometimes when you watch
things doing an NC you just cry you have
moments now you have moments of strange
sobriety where you snap out of the
trance the movie has put you in and you
suddenly have a split second we were
like what the fuck am I looking at what
am I seeing here and it was the most
bizarre collection of things it was this
chase with an ice cream truck a guy with
a puppets guy with a puppet like the
puppet like a dog on a skateboard yeah a
fat dog on escape in the countryside
like through a farm Tom and Jerry
there's a little girl whose father is
Indiana Jones yeah a little Tom Selleck
at the end oh yeah the Tom Selleck in
the other joke I just remember I turned
you them like Doug welcome to the
mindfuck I'm like this is just a my
phone this is the craziest that at that
point in doing the NCS that was probably
the craziest thing I've ever seen now
can the head and not come out yet so but
that was the crazy thing I ever seen I
think I just don't do it like we need to
play that paranoia song and then just
like yeah put all this together cuz me
yeah it was madness it was pure bad it
was probably the best thing to come out
of it you know I'm not gonna lie those
as horrible as this movie I actually
have fond memories of watching this
movie because I think it was so bad shit
insane and it was so bright and colorful
I was so obviously not Tom and Jerry
that we didn't even compare it at first
we were comparing it but then just like
the film it gave up tenets yeah 15
minutes into it it gave up altogether
and I just remember we we weren't even
looking at as a Tom and Jerry movie we
were just looking at it as a mindfuck
and as a mindfuck it was not only really
fun to watch but it's still one of my
favorite reviews yeah it's you know and
remember you see that coyote cartoon
where he tries so hard to get the
roadrunner brother robot just keeps my
boob BP by running off and file
at the end he liked the last one just
blows up they go through all this shit
and he just stands up totally you know
he's like Oh ash and flagons dumped me
they just goes boom that's what I felt
like with this movie I'm just like I'm
just gonna accept it I just you know
yeah just like another song oh okay oh
you're dancing yeah Jones oh okay
it is a puppet okay you can either break
down and cry
or if you can't beat them join them yeah
it was kind of that that was a movie
where it can the head I broke down and
cried and strangled you but this one I
just if you can't beat them join them
and like I had a lot of fun it was just
clearly a movie that was not meant to be
Tom and Jerry by any means they just
wrote this other film and said well
we're not doing that but we want a Tom
and Jerry movie although that's exactly
what this is and then I tell you what
starts off with Tom and Jerry the three
stooges plot like crumbled together with
every other Disney movie it's like stop
us if you've heard this a little girl
who is in the orphan whose parents are
missing gets stuck with an evil with
step-uncle we're spelling every mother's
it yeah and it's up to the cute cartoon
animals to save her and help her find
her day it literally like it went
through some sort of like automatic
script generator it's like you throw a
bunch of Disney ideas into like one
crank and then just a car and then this
movie's a fucking worst dad ever by the
way rip what a fuckin dead D that means
like just off doing zooming I talked
about in the other drones that way I'm
so like Indiana Jones would be very
angry uh just what they give in the Hat
and but it's like what are you doing
it's so insane and that's uh yeah you
just got a funny thing is when I
remember that scene where she saves him
with the helicopter I remember it now
because of the review with the Indiana
Jones music ah like I said it was
running yeah the ending tonight film was
running on Cartoon Network or something
about a year and a half ago and I'm just
like oh yeah watch a few minutes of this
cuz like this movie was just such a what
the fuck and I saw that see that I'm
like where's the Indiana Jones music I'm
like oh yeah that actually didn't happen
we put that job
start the flag you know and it's one of
those where I remember back seeing the
preview for this and you know I really
like Tom and Jerry as a kid I'm getting
into her fucking it's been a bad man
stuff like that I just see this tom and
jerry' I remember Tom and Jerry and this
is that just kiss felt nobody tried with
kids knows I mean nobody fucking made an
attempt and you just see Tom and Jerry
the movie you see Tom come through this
little hole and Jerry go up and it's
like an alkane you see a little bit of
violence oh that valves the one
commercial they showed is just the
violence you know so really only the
first two minutes they show that and
then they would show these other
commercials where they're singing and
dancing here's this little girl running
around something here's this fat dog on
a skateboard and we have to get her to
get the money and then everyone's like
oh and Tommy Jerry's in this to anyway
go see the movie and it was was that the
same commercial I saw there were these
two did they make a sequel already and
just get rid of the main character look
Doug we've got to have money
oh I feel bad I didn't make more of that
job that idea when I saw it was already
everywhere it's I'm like okay I won't
ever I post something on my public
Facebook about something dumb Hollywood
did is there's always somebody who posts
that one gram buddy Rob don't you know
this is how they think like we don't
have money you know I'll say this too
cuz every one of it like a few things I
got flack on in this movie I meet a guy
dude there's actually something to
defend this bill is the songs and I
really think that only because of the
guy who wrote them um I'm like as
anybody's guy buddy he did he Panther
right oh Mancini yeah Benson EJ he did
the songs for this they're so awful and
I hate that God also did the Great Mouse
Detective and how dare you know I do
love the music and the songs a Great
Mouse Detective I think they're
wonderful uh and I'm not at all saying
this guy's not talented but these are
awful I think if I'm not mistaken Christ
somebody would correct me if I even say
it I'm done now I'm just scared to I
think he did the Great Race uh boy it
sounds right
hey I don't know that's one of our
favorite calm you know what you know
what pooping we don't want to pick up
mancini sir no you know what
prove us wrong because then you had to
go see the great race which is a you
know it yeah so go prove us wrong don't
watch a movie before you treat you um
but ya know I have nothing against this
guys musician I just hate these songs
these are desica I'm just gonna say it
up front I don't even remember the songs
the only one I remember cuz I had a hand
know when when you edit I remember the
song to merarys I remember song some
great mouse detective I cannot for the
life if you put a gun to my head right
now and said hum one song from that Tom
and Jerry movie I couldn't do it I'd be
dead the only one I could do because I
had to edit it so many times is that we
do uh friends Tinian ain't it my friend
cuz I had a bet over be crying over and
over and I had to get that right I heard
over and over
ah but yeah you fuckin tell me that's a
good song the song that killed Tom and
Jerry
it wasn't the trade it was that song a
kill Tom and Jerry you just don't tell
me that that's why make that why break
the number one rule of Tom and Jerry I
think it's very clear they didn't they
said make a film and they didn't know
how to do a Tom and Jerry movie which
I'm not gonna lie who would nobody's
done it right yet even ones that do it
where I think there's like these little
straight-to-dvd things and stuff like
that and they're like Tom and Jerry what
with the fucking was an amaz or
something like that and it's just then
what it's pretty much just them watching
The Wizard of Oz if you just take like a
drawing at Tom and Jerry put it in the
corner of watching The Wizard of Oz I
think that's the movie well what I see I
haven't seen the whole thing but what
I've seen I'm like I they're just as
just a fortune our movie there aren't
many rules to Tom and Jerry there's
basically two they always fight they
always fight it was fight did you get
that I did okay I'm with you I'm wait
any comp accompli of stuff and they
don't talk they don't talk and no you
know what that okay I'll give you a
fighting for a minute oh but they have
to talk because I am not smart enough to
know how to tell a film where the two
characters don't talk even though that
used to be cinema for a year
thank you mommy silent but like my point
is is that there were only two rules and
then both of them oh um I'll meet you
rules you and you broke both they work
together they're kind of friendly like
throughout at least three-quarters of
this film and they fucking talk and I
just love how at the end for whatever
reason they start chasing you target
then they can freeze on the image of
this is the movie you saw you saw the
movie where they were chasing each other
Oh
even a fucking two-year-old would be
like a fucking stupid do you think I am
yeah the the only two things and and
they they could even do that and I'm
like if you can't even follow the most
simple like I I would have given credit
if they followed one out of the two
rules just one but you couldn't even
think they got there a cat and a mouse
and I'm not so sure I think they thought
that Jerry was a guinea pig
they thought they probably needed
instructions on that maybe thought he
was a puppy that's why they cast the
voice of max from true I actually I was
I was be tuned I am nothing against the
voice actors themselves they're very
good voice actors just not how I
imagined those voices I was actually
gonna say the exact opposite I will ever
say if they just walked like not too
traditional
whatever a uh hanna-barbera we did the
voice but uh you know not that voice
like hey if I was to listen to him they
were gonna talk well would they sound
like I know too much of that I thought
those wrong you and me now can never be
friend
no I I actually you know not that they
were funny but you know cuz the funny is
the way Tom yells Oh y-you know the
again I'm not gonna play a voice actors
for doing their job it's not their fault
but somebody in casting I think is just
not how I imagined it because Jerry you
know even though even though he's Meili
as opposed to these male and female
defeats you got these big eyelashes you
see max from goof troop like well but
but that's you know that's a woman doing
a boy voice and you know in both cases
so I thought that was actually an okay
choice and yeah you want time to be like
you know a little Barbie and you know
little bit of like you know some
swindler and stuff so yes I think that
boy is aware of a guy from I want it
there I want a Gerry to have the voice
of John Leguizamo and Tom they have the
voice of Christopher Walken um dad I
think Jerry don't you believe it we have
to help the girl why am i doing it I
thought I was gonna fight with you but
you know what that she looks so sad we
gotta do something no if I think too
that the clarification that this movie
was gonna be awful I mean aside from the
trailer this fucking movie
aside from the trailer is was I remember
I was walking through a bookstore they
had like a little kids magazine section
you know I don't know those are still
brown but everything had amazing
Garfield had a magazine there's a
Nintendo Power Looney Toons had a
magazine and they had these movie
magazines about just for a movie like
hey here's the duck tails the movie
magazine you can put stickers in there
you know you can do whatever activities
and they give away the film pretty much
they just show the whole film so I just
picked this up I'm just like let me just
see and I put through bottom like this
looks horrendous oh my god she kills
them she kills them then no doubt
interesting at least would have been
like oh I didn't expect that
yeah honestly it's the inexplicable 'ti
of the movie is one of it's saving
graces and of course the great Tony J
money even ways phoning it in it's like
yeah so she could read the phone book it
even sound great um I yeah I'm trying to
think if there's anything else you can
say about this we just well what do you
think you know what do you think of the
animation I'm afraid to call Warner
Brothers because we fucked up with Swan
Princess I was like you said it's the
best the best thing about it look it
over later or did they but yeah the best
thing about it I'm like oh I'll look it
up like with one of them it was like
Wikipedia had it as a Warner Brothers
film IMDB didn't and then like so I just
post about in my facebook and I was like
I posted image of like the Joker
breaking the pool cue in half I'm like
make it quick thank you guys argue it
out one side says one thing the other
says the other I've got other sides it
just like wasn't owned by one of us at
the time but checking one word about I
knew I own cinema and then I was
paralyzed I wonder come to the end just
like you would you guys argue that
because he owed you a soon princess
gonna assume there's more important
things to talk about so you guys unless
you actually worked on Swan Princess
yourself I'm not sure anybody cares I
think I got that much you know imagine
why go to the video store I had to go
through the kids section a lot because
we had to review on kids movies and
there's all these Swan Princess movie
something all had the warmer is logo
except the first one it's a warm breeze
didn't do the first one so I think
that's where I made the assumption but
you know think the only way you should
be offended as if you're at Warner Bros
it's like no even we didn't make Swan
Princess
hahahaha I get that you're not going
bitches we bought the sequels cuz you
know little money you know lecture
whatever but we did not make that shit
um but yeah but the animation you know
is again it's it's fine if it wasn't Tom
and Jerry okay I'm gonna go out on a
limb I don't know who made the time and
Jeremy because it's it's not really that
important to me I'm just gonna warn you
now Internet then in the grand scheme of
things that I need to know to get on in
life who made Tom and Jerry the movie is
not one of them I know how many people
would be jumping to claim that if I were
going to kiss if I were going to guess
the original Tom and Jerry was MGM so
would think that somehow in general yeah
that's true
yeah they did it the force of it maybe
maybe it was MGM but I don't remember
because it wasn't a good movie okay
you're sayin I that would be the
assumption I would make here's the thing
if he knows MGM then they have the
background for Tom and Jerry even though
they made some pretty bad ones later I
might talk about the Chuck Jones I'm
talking about the ones where they they
look like stick figures uh if it's
Warner Brothers clear they have years
and years of slapstick neither of those
could make the slapstick work in this uh
you know but it's it's color well it's
bright it's nice line work and stuff but
it's just clearly not funny you know it
looked you know what it reminded me of
um it looked
similar in some ways to the animation
and something like we're back a dinosaur
story yeah it's a bright colorful look
it was it was animated fine but I can't
say anything else about but just it was
fine yeah like it's not sticking out it
so I could be like oh it's like a good
Disney cartoon I can't even seems like a
really good time and Jerry cartoon like
a good Tom and Jerry cartoon the
slapstick is really hilarious I only
thought the slapstick was animated in
such a way that was like it was all
right like I don't you know I mean I
don't matter laughing once at the slats
I'm air laughing at the absurdity of
what was going on but never like hey
more the absurdity that I think we're
supposed to take this seriously you know
or whatever uh but never at the edge
will slapstick you know Alice a mature
how would like how would you do a Tom
and Jerry but why here they're going to
and CG or whatever honestly with well
step one don't but if we've decided to
ignore step one just like me ignore
don't talk and but here's the thing you
know it's it'd be very tricky John I
can't like it wouldn't be but I'm also
thinking of you know having seen Mad Max
it's like here's a movie that's like you
know 80% violence 80% chasing and you
know it it worked and it pushed it to
sort of this little of oh I did this is
gonna sound insane happened you know I
know if I would do it in this is gonna
sound insane but you would almost have
to do it like something like baby's day
out where it's a simple concept and I
hated that movie by the way so I'm not
saying I'm supporting another baby's day
out but the concept of a simple idea the
baby wanders out in this case the
cat-and-mouse fight and you somehow drag
it outside and make it more epic than it
really is getting wrapped up and under
the story but not not like what they do
or it's just like we're just going to
insert them in The Wizard of Oz or we're
going to have them help some orphan girl
find your dad if those things happen
they happen by accident they don't
happen because they're making a
conscious effort to help people it
should be like they're having this
constant fight and getting wrapped up in
other stories that all resolved
themselves pretty much because of their
fight I would find like mr. bean like
the way mr. bean wanders around and you
can see there's these other stories
going on then
even having a fucked up the movie for
hats yeah but I'm not talking about the
movie he's talking about yeah no that's
sort of what that's watching it that
it's Ament that was the same promise of
Tom and Jerry movie it's like well mr.
bean has to deal with his consequences
and help these people I want to see that
who likes to say that it's one of those
where it's like I could see it being
done like just unapologetic pushing it
all the way like you said just starting
in one spot just the chase goes and they
just go through whatever yeah outside on
top of buildings and stuff and it's
almost like they never rest just you
know what I know that's not how movies
work I know you're supposed to care
about character I know it's supposed to
be like this right and probably a lot of
people are going here but you know what
we're gonna do it to the Oh life of art
I think you should rest within the same
way that my exterior as I here's five
minutes of silence just to remind you
what it sounds like yeah and then just
go right back yeah just have it be like
a rush and nobody would do that back
then you know nobody would dare
especially on a kiss Phil nobody would
risk that at all uh but at the same time
it's like if it was to be done that's
like I'm not saying that is the only way
there could be another way but that's
what I can in my head word so you just
had to go balls to the wall in your face
like Oh rush I said adrenaline rush and
just make it like this fucking roller
coaster crazy and like you said just get
to bigger and bigger and bigger and then
maybe some somehow they get their way
back home and they're just like
breathing heavily and maybe they just
like you know like shake hands truce and
they co answer like that'd be the movie
and nobody could say that wasn't a Tom
and Jerry movie I mean everyone can play
that the commentary movie you'd say
that's not Tom and Jerry but it even
like The Wizard of Oz and or like these
mysteries or whatever they're doing uh
yeah I still look at like like I never
see one all the way through I've seen
the quints and bits and pieces and stuff
uh but like you know I watch I'm like
well killer they're acting like Tom and
Jerry but they're not you know this is
your yacht if the environment for Tom
and Jerry
it's very scooby-doo it's like Scooby in
the gang meet the Harlem Globetrotters
Tom and Jerry meet the Wizard of Oz Adam
and Costello Meet Frankenstein and the
scooby-doo gang
and coming here like it just not I mean
so it's at least with like the Wizard of
Oz and stuff I understand why they're
going that route cause it's all a you're
introducing it to you you have whatever
the MGM and stuff like that I'm sure
well you did you have your property you
have your rights you have your story you
don't need a new story you can you know
end story and insert your characters
into it so you don't have to worry about
what to do with it yeah and it's like
just you don't know it's hard to figure
out what to do with them I'm not gay and
I'm not I'm not gonna say that that's a
good idea but that idea at least from a
certain perspective makes a lot more
sense
yeah than what they did with this movie
or it's like we're gonna create a whole
new story involving organs and get
Amanda another two rooms they don't talk
don't talk
and they chase each other you know at
the very least um so yeah even if like
whatever they're like caught with like
the whatever those scarecrow and
everybody they're just skipping along
with them it's like that happens in
other Tom and Jerry cartoons where
they'll kind of get distracted you know
in the Tommy Jerry movie they officially
say we're done we are never fighting
again we will always be buddies we will
I mean it it's aa duty damage is
thinking about it um but no honestly out
of all the films that we've watched like
I said my memories of this era to not
like mean hate-filled ma'am I don't like
what they did but it was so no no see
it's so bizarre and I just range yeah in
a strange way I Chi I feel the same way
I I don't like this movie but it's
entertaining to watch almost in a room
sort of way yeah it's almost like a
Tommy was so kind of project it's just
like it's so far removed from Tom and
Jerry that you're just like okay you
can't even say like neverending story
three pissed me off more than this ever
did so I it's just so far removes itself
I can't even say you're not even
shooting on Tom and Jerry because it's
not even Tom and Jerry anymore yeah um
and it is so bad shit crazy and just
what just what the hell were you
thinking it's like watching somebody
completely stoned relate to you a story
about a talking Mouse and I think
there's also something to you just
clearly know going in like these people
are not
get it there's no way for them to get it
so you just you're not even that like
you know what person Ola doesn't like
Darnay risers and said that's like no
you did Dark Knight right and oh how how
did this happen
you know with something like this you
just no get nothing you're not gonna get
this they're not going to capture God
Tom and Jerry and how they are and stuff
so you just sort of shrug and go yeah
okay whatever well that's the other
difference never ending story three like
we had a progression of films that at
least were within 15-20 years of each
other whereas Tom and Jerry it's like
okay we hadn't had a Tom and Jerry movie
yeah ever the cartoons would just been
running in syndication like the original
cartoons and made new ones and well over
like 20 years or something so it at
least it just felt so far removed that I
can just be like you know what whatever
doesn't exist yeah
so but yeah there it is um both a little
more in a little less hate I'll bet if
he people Brian are going really target
yeah Normie clouds
God has a thing for this yeah baby the
automatic exposure always goes like
either super bright or super dark so I
try to set it right and then we just got
story talking about Tom and Jerry and
then the storm yeah I know it's just
like you know that's that's what happens
man get inside but the Tama tunic is
like black outside yeah spike in here
doctor ed at least so um I knew we
should have done a different movie um
anything else we do love friends to
being ain't we my friend I'm coming
never talked before cuz we have better
writers